c'est une annonce qui risque de raviver
une fois de plus les tensions entre
athènes et ankara la turquie a annoncé
ce dimanche le lancement d'une nouvelle
mission en méditerranée du navire
d'exploration leur crès les travaux de
maintenance de notre navire de
recherches sismiques sont terminés notre
navire a jeté l'ancré pour prendre des
radiographies de la méditerranée nous
continuerons de rechercher de creuser et
de protéger nos droits
s'il y en a nous le trouverons sûrement
leur creil c'était déjà au coeur de la
discorde entre les deux pays en août
dernier
escorté par des bâtiments de guerre il
avait mené des recherches dans les eaux
territoriales grecques revendiquée par
la turquie à la recherche d'un gaz
naturel de son côté la glace revendique
sa souveraineté sur ses espaces
maritimes
mais ankara souhaite des droits plus
étendus en méditerranée orientale en
raison de son littoral plus long en écho
aux échanges tendus quasi quotidiens le
mois dernier le ministère grec des
affaires étrangères avait déjà condamné
fermement l'attitude de la turquie
malheureusement la délinquance turque
dans l'ensemble de la région continue à
gagner en intensité et à s'étendre dans
l'espace du caucase la libye en passant
par la mer egée chypre la méditerranée
orientale la syrie et l'irak
la grèce a constaté que le départ de
l'oru creis était la première étape de
la désescalade
nous espérons que cette étape ouvrira la
voie au contact entre la grèce et la
turquie afin de délimiter la zone
économique exclusive et le plateau
continental j'en us
le ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères et ico masse doit se rendre à
ankara ce mercredi pour une rencontre au
cours de laquelle la question de la
méditerranée orientale occupera une
place centrale